Shure:  咳
Shure: Cough
Shure:  有有我这有
Shure: I have it, I have it here.
Shure:  这有这有这有
Shure: Here, here, I got it.
Shure:  也有
Shure: Got it.
Shure:  瓶子特别多但是也够用
Shure: There are a lot of bottles, but it's enough.
Shure:  这是什么
Shure: What's this?
Shure:  这是你的论文是吗
Shure: Is this your thesis?
Shure:  这这个服务吗
Shure: Is this the service?
Shure:  卧槽
Shure: Whoa
Shure:  这这段先别录先掐了是吧
Shure: Don't record this part, let's stop it first.
Shure:  天呐我们这弄一个多少钱
Shure: Oh my, how much does it cost for us to do one?
Shure:  我觉得5,000吧
Shure: I think, 5,000?
Shure:  差不多
Shure: About right.
Shure:  纯论文是吗
Shure: Pure thesis, right?
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah
Shure:  那你这帮人提供免费润色
Shure: So, your team provides free editing?
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn
Tasha: 一开始我毕业的时候帮我们班同学写
Tasha: At the beginning, when I graduated, I helped my classmates write.
Tasha: 然后我们班推荐
Tasha: Then our class recommended...
Tasha: 下一届下一届
Tasha: The next batch, next batch.
Shure:  等一下OK
Shure: Wait a minute, okay.
Shure:  这个一会一会
Shure: We'll discuss this later.
Shure:  不录的时候咱俩咱俩细研究一下
Shure: When we're not recording, let's study it in detail.
Shure:  是的你这个好像没亮
Shure: Yes, it seems yours is not on.
Alice: 因为我没开啊
Alice: Because I didn't turn it on.
Alice: 现在要开什么
Alice: Do you want me to turn it on now?
Shure:  可以开了可以开了
Shure: You can turn it on, go ahead.
Shure:  你提供英文代写吗
Shure: Do you provide English ghostwriting?
Tasha: 我不提供英文代写
Tasha: I don't provide English ghostwriting.
Shure:  那你就完蛋
Shure: Then you're out of luck.
Tasha: 干什么自己写吧
Tasha: Come on, write it yourself.
Shure:  我24交这周然后
Shure: I'm submitting it on the 24th this week...
Shure:  其实写的差不多了
Shure: It's almost done.
Jake: 写什么呀
Jake: Writing what?
Tasha: 论文啊
Tasha: A thesis.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Shure:  我们饭今天已经点好了对吧
Shure: We've already ordered food for today, right?
Tasha: 是的
Tasha: Yes.
Shure:  然后还差什么
Shure: What else is missing?
Shure:  还有多久到
Shure: How long until it arrives?
Jake: 还有多久到
Jake: How much longer until we get there?
Shure:  这么不靠谱吗他们
Shure: How can they be so unreliable?
Lucia: 喂
Lucia: Hello?
Tasha: 1133
Tasha: 1133.
Shure:  嗯行
Shure: Okay, got it.
Tasha: 到门口了
Tasha: I'm at the entrance.
Tasha: 用不用
Tasha: Do you need it?
Katrina:  昨天的这些旧的是不是可以删掉了
Katrina: Can we delete these old ones from yesterday?
Jake: 呀对对对对
Jake: Oh, right, right, right.
Katrina:  那他一会别又
Katrina: So he doesn't...
Jake: 对眼镜都删掉才可以
Shure:  然后这样他们的时间码就对上了是吗
Shure: So this way their timestamps will match, right?
Shure:  可以啊
Shure: Sounds good.
Shure:  想想咱们烤肉今天要买什么
Shure: Let's think about what we need to buy for the BBQ today.
Shure:  我可我可要把我祖传的手艺拿出来了
Shure: I'm going to show off my family's secret recipe.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure:  我们家传到我这边已经是第17代了
Shure: Our family has passed it down to me, and I'm the 17th generation.
Shure:  楼上楼下
Shure: Upstairs and downstairs.
Shure:  上国内的就会很慢
Shure: It will be very slow on domestic ones.
Alice: 查小红书的时候
Alice: When I was checking Xiaohongshu,
Alice: 他给我推了一些奇怪的内容
Alice: It recommended some weird stuff to me.
Alice: 我还点进去看了
Alice: I even clicked on it.
Alice: 我觉得很社死怎么办
Alice: I feel so socially dead, what should I do?
Alice: 还录下来了
Alice: And I recorded it.
Alice: 哈哈哈无所谓吧
Alice: Hahaha, whatever.
Lucia: 应该他们会处理吧
Lucia: They should take care of it, right?
Alice: 无所谓喽
Alice: Whatever.
Lucia: 没事我觉得我们打开社交软件时候
Lucia: It's okay, I think when we open social media,
Lucia: 肯定会出现各种
Lucia: There are always all kinds of...
Alice: 巨尴尬无比的东西哈哈哈
Alice: Super awkward stuff, hahaha.
Shure:  吃饭吗
Shure: Want to eat?
Tasha: 走吧
Tasha: Let's go.
Shure:  哦哦我们是活动
Shure: Oh, oh, we have an event.
Shure:  还有交换礼物的活动是吗
Shure: And we have a gift exchange event, right?
Shure:  是要带着礼物上去吗
Shure: Should we bring the gifts up?
Tasha: 啊先不用了  啊好
Tasha: Ah, no need yet. Ah, okay.
Shure:   好
Shure: Alright.
Shure:  哎呦完了
Shure: Oh no.
Shure:  我刚喝完咖啡
Shure: I just finished my coffee.
Shure:  喝不出来
Shure: I can't taste it.
Katrina:  我也是
Katrina: Me neither.
Shure:  一会漱一下口吧
Shure: Let's rinse our mouths in a bit.
Lucia: 品尝饮料
Lucia: Tasting drinks.
Lucia: 饮料好像已经快被我们喝光了
Lucia: Looks like we've almost finished all the drinks.
Lucia: 我记得
Lucia: I remember.
Tasha: 还有存货
Tasha: There's still some left.
Katrina:  天呐感觉有那个魔鬼料理
Katrina: Oh my gosh, it feels like that devil's cuisine.
Shure:  漱我口
Shure: Let me rinse my mouth.
Alice: 呃那那我等你吧
Alice: Uh, then I'll wait for you.
Jake: 礼物一会再拿
Jake: We'll get the gifts later.
Jake: 喝完这个排完名之后再拿
Jake: After we finish drinking and ranking.
Alice: 那要特别急的话我就选择叫你
Alice: If it's really urgent, I'll call you.
Lucia: 对哦就是很急
Lucia: Yeah, it's really urgent.
Lucia: 你上去了吧
Lucia: Did you go upstairs?
Katrina:  我靠他居然能敷上去
Katrina: Wow, I can't believe he managed to apply it.
Katrina:  哇哈哈有点急
Katrina: Haha, it's a bit urgent.
Alice: 这个让我的花花面对着你
Alice: Let my flower face you.
Tasha: 然后从每个杯子里尝出不同的水
Tasha: Then taste the different waters from each cup.
Jake: yes
Jake: Yes.
Katrina:  yes
Katrina: Yes.
Lucia: 不会吧
Lucia: No way.
Shure:  怡宝我肯定一眼能尝出来
Shure: I can definitely recognize Yibao right away.
Alice: 我要把我花花对着
Alice: I'll face my flower to you.
Shure:  因为怡宝和农夫山泉
Shure: Because Yibao and Nongfu Spring.
Shure:  这两个我都能尝出来
Shure: I can recognize both of them.
Shure:  走吧走吧
Shure: Let's go, let's go.
Alice: 嗯好的
Alice: Mm, okay.
Shure:  哎呦真的这咖啡
Shure: Oh man, this coffee.
Shure:  早说这个活动不喝咖啡
Shure: Should've said no coffee for this event.
Shure:  先擦擦舌头
Shure: Wipe the tongue first.
Katrina:  擦擦舌头
Katrina: Wipe the tongue.
Jake: 擦一擦
Jake: Wipe it.
Alice: 这是什么
Alice: What is this?
Alice: 这是
Alice: This is...
Alice: 苏打水跟什么
Alice: Soda water with what?
Shure:  水水水水水水水
Shure: Water, water, water, water, water, water, water.
Alice: 这个不是有气泡吗
Alice: Isn't this fizzy?
Shure:  啊只有一杯是那个元气森林
Shure: Ah, only one cup is Yuanqi Forest.
Shure:  其他都是普通的
Shure: The rest are just plain water.
Alice: 这是要干嘛
Alice: What are we doing?
Lucia: 这是
Lucia: This is
Shure:  品鉴
Shure: A tasting
Lucia: 品鉴不同的水
Lucia: Tasting different waters
Jake: 好请大家请坐
Jake: Alright, everyone please sit down.
Jake: 各就各位
Jake: Take your places.
Jake: 齐了吗没齐
Jake: Is everyone ready? No, not yet.
Jake: 大家挑一个位置吧
Jake: Everyone choose a seat.
Jake: 座位也不太重要
Jake: The seating doesn't really matter.
Jake: 薇薇干嘛去了
Jake: Where's Tasha?
Shure:  薇薇有点急事
Shure: Tasha has something urgent.
Jake: 哦莫急莫急
Jake: Oh, no rush, no rush.
Alice: 这个这个
Alice: This, this
Alice: 放这吧放那边吧
Alice: Put it here, or over there.
Tasha: 你要不坐那啊
Tasha: Why don't you sit there?
Shure:  你坐那没有想Siri
Shure: If you sit there, it doesn't seem like Siri.
Shure:  尝试一下king
Shure: Try it, king.
Alice: 哪个要喝了吗
Alice: Are we going to drink it now?
Jake: 等等一下吧
Jake: Let's wait a bit.
Jake: 就是薇薇她是出不来是吧
Jake: So, Tasha can't make it out, right?
Alice: 呃几分钟就好了
Alice: Uh, just a few minutes.
Jake: 好那等等她吧
Jake: Okay, let's wait for her.
Alice: 你不会要喝哪哪个的味道吧
Alice: You won't drink any of those flavors, right?
Shure:  是的yes
Shure: Yes, yes.
Shure:  你觉得你能尝出来吗
Shure: Do you think you can tell the difference?
Katrina:  我从来没有留意过
Katrina: I've never really paid attention.
Katrina:  就是不同矿泉水的味道
Katrina: Like, the taste of different mineral waters.
Shure:  你不会就忠于买哪个牌子吗
Shure: So you don't stick to one brand?
Katrina:  不会啊随便买
Katrina: No, I just buy whatever.
Katrina:  不是哪个价格低就买哪个
Katrina: I buy whichever is cheaper.
Shure:  我就不爱喝农夫山泉
Shure: I just don't like Nongfu Spring.
Shure:  其他都可以
Shure: Anything else is fine.
Shure:  所以农夫山泉一定能尝
Shure: So I can definitely taste Nongfu Spring.
Shure:  然后最爱喝的是怡宝啊
Shure: My favorite is Yibao.
Alice: 对怡宝甜
Alice: Yeah, Yibao is sweet.
Shure:  对怡宝是甜
Shure: Yes, Yibao is sweet.
Shure:  农夫山泉根本不甜
Shure: Nongfu Spring is not sweet at all.
Shure:  好像怡宝是偏一点酸性
Shure: It seems like Yibao is a bit more acidic.
Shure:  说是不是那么健康
Shure: They say it's not that healthy.
Katrina:  哪个
Katrina: Which one?
Shure:  怡宝  就是它PH值
Shure: Yibao, it's about its pH level.
Katrina:  哪个水最好来着
Katrina: Which water is the best again?
Shure:  娃哈哈哦
Shure: Wahaha, oh.
Alice: 娃哈哈最啥实
Alice: Wahaha is the best for what?
Shure:  实验用水都是
Shure: All the experiment water is.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 好这个
Jake: Alright, this one.
Jake: 怎么说呢
Jake: How to put it...
Jake: 先不要说话
Jake: First, don't talk.
Jake: 然后写答案
Jake: Then write your answers.
Jake: 好可以开始
Jake: Okay, you can start.
Jake: 不要交流
Jake: Don't communicate.
Jake: 对 不要
Jake: Yes, don't.
Jake: 写写写充电宝
Jake: Write, write, write power bank.
Shure:  写充电宝
Shure: Write power bank.
Jake: 上来发充电宝
Jake: Come up and distribute the power banks.
Shure:  我的充电宝真的都当手卡用
Shure: I really use my power bank as a hand card.
Tasha: 只有一根笔吧
Tasha: There's only one pen, right?
Jake: 对一支笔
Jake: Yes, one pen.
Jake: 或者哈哈
Jake: Or, haha.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Lucia: 我记得楼下有便签啊哎
Lucia: I remember there's a sticky note downstairs.
Jake: 对用便签也可以
Jake: Yes, sticky notes are fine too.
Jake: 但是笔就这么一点
Jake: But there's only this one pen.
Katrina:  我有笔我有笔
Katrina: I have a pen, I have a pen.
Alice: 现在是不是可以开始尝了
Alice: Can we start tasting now?
Alice: 吧
Alice: Or...
Jake: 什么什么
Jake: What, what?
Alice: 可以开始喝了吧
Alice: Can we start drinking now?
Jake: 可以上了
Jake: You can start.
Katrina:  一直连不上啊
Katrina: It just won't connect.
Shure:  没开机吧
Shure: Maybe it's not turned on.
Jake: 确实
Jake: Indeed.
Jake: 很有可能
Jake: Very likely.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  你别别这么夸
Shure: Don't exaggerate like that.
Shure:  哈哈哈我没法接了哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha, I can't continue like this, hahaha.
Lucia: 应该说不愧是我
Lucia: You should say, "as expected of me."
Shure:  这怎么还甜呢
Shure: Why is this still sweet?
Shure:  不是他哎呀
Shure: It's not... oh man.
Jake: 不准说话啊
Jake: Don't talk, okay?
Jake: 可以就是把握尺度啊
Jake: You can, but keep it in check.
Jake: 就是保证你们答案不一样
Jake: Just make sure your answers are different.
Shure:  嗯这个尝试
Shure: Yeah, this attempt.
Alice: 好像咖啡喝啥都一个味
Alice: It seems like coffee tastes the same no matter what.
Lucia: 完了
Lucia: Done.
Shure:  有这个应该提前通知我们一下
Shure: We should have been informed about this in advance.
Jake: 咖啡还是得喝的
Jake: You still have to drink coffee.
Jake: 对吧好
Jake: Right, okay.
Tasha: 这瓶是矿泉水
Tasha: This bottle is mineral water.
Katrina:  这应该是没有装对芯吗
Katrina: Shouldn't this have the right cartridge?
Shure:  这跟我高中时用的一样
Shure: This is just like what I used in high school.
Tasha: 这个是矿泉水
Tasha: This is mineral water.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake: 哈哈矿泉水
Jake: Haha, mineral water.
Jake: 对是谢彬主带来的
Jake: Yes, it's from Xie Bin Zhu.
Tasha: 你不用喝都知道
Tasha: You know it even without tasting.
Jake: 好酷这个
Jake: This is so cool.
Jake: 我我们找到一些环保的方案哈哈哈
Jake: We found some eco-friendly solutions, haha.
Lucia: 废物利用
Lucia: Waste utilization.
Jake: 太环保了
Jake: So eco-friendly.
Tasha: 这个餐巾纸我想要一张
Tasha: I want a piece of this napkin.
Tasha: 这倒的漏出来了水好不好意思
Tasha: It spilled, sorry about that.
Jake: 不差了不差了
Jake: It's not bad, not bad.
Jake: 然后这边有好几支笔
Jake: And there are several pens here.
Lucia: 我是不是得用这种啊
Lucia: Should I use this one?
Lucia: 你也是可以
Lucia: You can too.
Jake: 你们就换着用
Jake: You guys can switch.
Jake: 或者有没有纸
Jake: Or do you have paper?
Lucia: 这样我就可以用
Lucia: Then I can use it.
Tasha: 这这个是怎么怎么呢
Tasha: How do we do this?
Tasha: 怎么写编号呢
Tasha: How to write the number?
Tasha: 哦哦123456
Tasha: Oh, oh, 123456.
Jake: 对哦嗯
Jake: Yes, oh, uh-huh.
Jake: 我我我我我觉得这个有点小
Jake: I think this is a bit small.
Lucia: 他写不下啊
Lucia: It doesn't fit.
Shure:  好
Shure: Okay.
Lucia: 底下还有这种黑纸盒吗
Lucia: Are there more of these black paper boxes below?
Lucia: 730以后再喝别的来
Lucia: Let's drink something else after 7:30.
Jake: 这样
Jake: Like this.
Lucia: Oh Jesus
Katrina:  随便写吧
Katrina: Just write whatever
Shure:  你肯定先避开下一个
Shure: You should definitely avoid the next one
Tasha: 我觉得这应该写ABCDE
Tasha: I think this should be written as ABCDE
Jake: 对
Jake: Right
Jake: 其实你们有些人带着充电宝对吧
Jake: Actually, some of you brought portable chargers, right?
Shure:  是的
Shure: Yes
Jake: 你自己
Jake: Yourself
Lucia: 哎这样可以少写好些字对
Lucia: Hey, this way we can write fewer words, right?
Shure:  这次都不用尝就看出来了啊
Shure: This time we don't even need to taste, we can just see it
Katrina:  转一个弯
Katrina: Take a turn
Katrina:  最纯净哦
Katrina: The purest one
Shure:  写写写编号对
Shure: Write, write, write the number, right
Lucia: 有的水喝过来没记住那个味怎么办
Lucia: What if I drank the water but can't remember the taste?
Tasha: 尝不出来啊
Tasha: Can't tell the difference
Jake: 多尝几次
Jake: Taste it a few more times
Jake: 哈哈多尝几次
Jake: Haha, taste it a few more times
Lucia: 喝完了快
Lucia: Finished drinking quickly
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake: 这么这么渴吗
Jake: Are you that thirsty?
Alice: 不是尝尝尝尝
Alice: No, just tasting
Lucia: 刚好补充水分
Lucia: Just replenishing water
Katrina:  交卷
Katrina: Hand in the paper
Katrina:  嗯没有笔吗
Katrina: Hmm, no pen?
Shure:  3都长出来了
Shure: Number 3 has already grown
Katrina:  整的现在
Katrina: Fix it now
Jake: 尝出来了
Jake: Figured it out
Katrina:  鉴酒似的
Katrina: Like wine tasting
Lucia: 嗯可以可以
Lucia: Hmm, okay, okay
Lucia: 能写就行
Lucia: As long as you can write
Jake: a b c d f
Jake: 我也想尝尝
Jake: I also want to try
Jake: 一会再尝
Jake: Try it later
Jake: 我们一会再尝尝
Jake: We'll try it later
Shure:  摸温度哈哈哈好聪明
Shure: Feel the temperature, haha, so smart
Tasha: 有一瓶好冰啊
Tasha: One bottle is really cold
Jake: 啊哦真的
Jake: Ah, really?
Alice: 在哪啊不是在哪洗
Alice: Where is it? I mean, where to wash?
Shure:  我估计应该最冰的是他
Shure: I guess the coldest one is his
Shure:  因为他最大
Shure: Because it's the biggest
Shure:  有没有可能
Shure: Is it possible
Tasha: 有一瓶好冰啊
Tasha: There's a really cold bottle here
Alice: 哎答案写在哪啊
Alice: Hey, where's the answer written?
Katrina:  掰一下给你
Katrina: Let me break it for you
Alice: 哦可以可以
Alice: Oh, okay, okay
Alice: 不过我按我的顺序跟他对一下
Alice: But I'll match it with my order first
Katrina:  好这样写
Katrina: Alright, write it like this
Alice: 这样可以
Alice: This works
Alice: 这是啥呀甲
Alice: What's this, Alpha?
Katrina:  拿这写也行
Katrina: You can write with this too
Shure:  f
Shure: F
Shure:  这是f的话题
Shure: This is an F topic
Shure:  是吗
Shure: Right?
Jake: 我不知道
Jake: I don't know
Jake: 我乱写
Jake: I just wrote randomly
Tasha: 有白板笔吗
Tasha: Do we have a whiteboard marker?
Jake: 样题
Jake: Sample question
Shure:  我绝对不能把我的一包选错
Shure: I absolutely cannot choose the wrong pack
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Katrina:  拭目以待
Katrina: We'll see
Lucia: 能从这个圆这瓶里再倒出来喝吗
Lucia: Can we pour out from this round bottle to drink?
Shure:  疯了
Shure: Crazy
Lucia: 不是
Lucia: No
Shure:  哦
Shure: Oh
Lucia: 比较一下吗
Lucia: Just compare
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure
Shure:  没有空杯子
Shure: No empty cups
Lucia: 喝完某一个就好了
Lucia: Just finish one of them then
Jake: 我们有几位已经整出来了吗感觉
Jake: Do we have a few people who have already finished, it seems?
Jake: 已经交卷了
Jake: Already handed in
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah
Jake: 这么牛逼
Jake: So impressive
Katrina:  主要是我从来
Katrina: Mainly because I never
Jake: 我看一看建浩老师
Jake: I'll take a look at Mr. Jianhao
Jake: 来看你的答案
Jake: Let's see your answers
Katrina:  哈哈哈鹅
Katrina: Hahaha, goose
Shure:  猜
Shure: Guess
Katrina:  主要是全不会
Katrina: Mainly because I know nothing
Katrina:  就跟那种完全没学过一样
Katrina: It's like I've never learned this at all
Katrina:  然后哈哈哈
Katrina: And then hahaha
Jake: 就可以替身交卷
Jake: You can submit your paper now.
Shure:  都选c吧
Shure: Let's all pick C.
Shure:  那不就
Shure: Then it would...
Katrina:  对啊
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  但是都写怡宝
Katrina: But write down "Yibao" for everything.
Katrina:  总有一个对的
Katrina: One of them has to be right.
Lucia: 好有道理
Lucia: Makes sense.
Katrina:  矿泉水
Katrina: Bottled water.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 我打算都写怡宝
Lucia: I'm going to write "Yibao" for everything.
Jake: 哈哈我看看你的怡宝对不对
Jake: Haha, let me see if your "Yibao" is correct.
Shure:  是不是对的
Shure: Is it right?
Jake: 不知道
Jake: I don't know.
Shure:  你看监考是回避我的
Shure: See, the proctor avoids me.
Alice: 给
Alice: Here.
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 那我还能怎么说呢
Jake: What else can I say?
Jake: 看一看
Jake: Let's see.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Alice: 怎么了
Alice: What's up?
Jake: 没看明白
Jake: I don't get it.
Jake: 就是要要倒一下顺序
Jake: We need to reverse the order.
Shure:  我交卷了老师
Shure: I've submitted my paper, teacher.
Jake: 这样吧你们你们按照这个字母12123456
Jake: How about this, you guys follow this sequence 1, 2, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6.
Jake: 然后按照字母顺一下
Jake: Then arrange them by letter.
Jake: 不然我们这个就是像选择题答案一样
Jake: Otherwise, it'll just look like multiple-choice answers.
Jake: 知道吧我们一会对
Jake: You know, we'll check it later.
Jake: 一会我们就会报这个
Jake: Later, we'll announce it like...
Jake: EFCD之类的
Jake: EFCD or something.
Jake: 这种
Jake: Like that.
Shure:  没问题
Shure: No problem.
Jake: 来写一下
Jake: Let's write it down.
Jake: 没没看明白就是
Jake: I don't get it, just...
Jake: 交卷
Jake: Submit.
Alice: 就是一到六
Alice: It's just 1 to 6.
Jake: 答题卡答题卡
Jake: Answer sheet, answer sheet.
Tasha: 44
Tasha: 44.
Alice: 23
Alice: 23.
Tasha: 1
Tasha: 1.
Tasha: 55
Tasha: 55.
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey
Jake: 给收卷
Jake: Time to collect the papers
Lucia: 纯净水的矿泉水
Lucia: Pure mineral water
Jake: 好收卷
Jake: Okay, collecting papers
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Jake: 收卷
Jake: Collecting papers
Lucia: 完了
Lucia: Done
Lucia: 卷子没写完
Lucia: Didn't finish the test
Tasha: 哎
Tasha: Hey
Katrina:  答题卡没涂
Katrina: Didn't mark the answer sheet
Shure:  答题卡没涂
Shure: Didn't mark the answer sheet
Katrina:  哎
Katrina: Hey
Jake: 不着急不着急
Jake: No rush, no rush
Jake: 再品一品
Jake: Take your time
Jake: 说实话农夫山泉那杯我一定选对
Jake: Honestly, I definitely picked the Nongfu Spring
Katrina:  这有啥区别
Katrina: What's the difference
Shure:  农夫山泉跟他们那个确实打的不一样
Shure: Nongfu Spring really tastes different from theirs
Shure:  农夫山泉明显不甜
Shure: Nongfu Spring is clearly not sweet
Shure:  你知道吗
Shure: You know?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Shure:  我还有一个同学
Shure: I have a classmate
Shure:  只要一喝农夫山泉就会拉的
Shure: Who gets diarrhea just from drinking Nongfu Spring
Jake: 对对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah
Katrina:  太那个什么经典说娃哈哈的公子
Katrina: So classic, talking about the Wahaha prince
Shure:  哈哈哈只能喝娃哈哈
Shure: Hahaha, can only drink Wahaha
Lucia: 不好意思三五
Lucia: Sorry, three-five
Tasha: 我就只能喝我就尝出来了娃哈哈的味
Tasha: I can only drink it, I can taste Wahaha's flavor
Lucia: 一个都尝不出来
Lucia: Can't taste any of them
Katrina:  我去真的
Katrina: Oh my god, really
Alice: 这个可以
Alice: This one is good
Katrina:  这一般是便利店里有
Katrina: This one is usually at convenience stores
Katrina:  什么买哪个便宜卖哪个
Katrina: They sell whichever is cheaper
Lucia: 那个可以看看
Lucia: You can take a look at that
Jake: 答题卡是不是都没写名字呀
Jake: Did everyone forget to write their names on the answer sheets?
Jake: 谁是谁啊
Jake: Who is who?
Jake: 一会互相面面
Jake: We'll know each other's
Jake: 大家都知道
Jake: Everyone will know
Jake: 大家都知道对
Jake: Everyone will know, yeah
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm
Katrina:  今天我的生日
Katrina: Today's my birthday.
Shure:  批卷是吧
Shure: Grading papers, right?
Katrina:  要把这
Katrina: Got to do this...
Jake: 批卷准备
Jake: Prepare for grading.
Jake: 批卷
Jake: Grading.
Lucia: 这些其他能不能多选一个答案啊
Lucia: Can we choose more than one answer for these?
Lucia: 这样保证至少有对的
Lucia: That way, at least one will be right.
Jake: 可以啊可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Jake: 这个策略是可以的哈哈
Jake: That's a feasible strategy, haha.
Shure:  快递放在一楼椅子上了
Shure: The package is on the chair on the first floor.
Jake: 好嘞
Jake: Got it.
Shure:  太有那个高中监考老师那味了
Shure: Feels just like a high school proctor.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Tasha: 走来走去
Tasha: Pacing around.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  在晃悠
Shure: Wandering around.
Shure:  然后那个拖鞋还咔咔咔的声你知道吗
Shure: And the slippers making that "clack clack clack" sound, you know?
Tasha: 啪啪啪
Tasha: "Clap clap."
Jake: 然后没事看一看你们的答案
Jake: Then casually checking your answers.
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  然后咂一声
Katrina: Then making a sound.
Katrina:  嗯然后这个同学就慌
Katrina: And then the student gets nervous.
Shure:  然后在他旁边叹口气唉唉
Shure: Then sighing next to the student, like "sigh, sigh."
Alice: 唉
Alice: Sigh.
Jake: 再指指点点
Jake: Then pointing here and there.
Jake: 这题写错了
Jake: "You got this question wrong."
Tasha: 点 就是不说话
Tasha: Pointing, without saying a word.
Jake: 帮2分呵呵
Jake: Deducting 2 points, hehe.
Alice: 也不当就这样
Alice: Not even talking, just like that.
Alice: 就指点一下
Alice: Just pointing.
Lucia: 然后就这样吧
Lucia: And then that's it.
Jake: 好的互相p吧
Jake: Alright, let's grade each other's papers.
Jake: 我们也不想看
Jake: We don't want to look at them either.
Shure:  互相p照
Shure: Grading each other's papers.
Shure:  我天
Shure: Oh my.
Katrina:  我天呐天呐天呐
Katrina: Oh my gosh, oh my gosh.
Shure:  真的是给外国人一些
Shure: Seriously, give some to foreigners.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Shure:  这是我自个的
Shure: This one's mine.
Katrina:  这这不是我的吗
Katrina: Isn't this mine?
Jake: 这是
Jake: This is...
Lucia: 啊写了写了
Lucia: Ah, wrote it down, wrote it down.
Shure:  那个我也写这个啊
Shure: I also wrote this one.
Lucia: 这我自己认
Lucia: I recognize this myself.
Tasha: 这什么意思啊
Tasha: What does this mean?
Tasha: 看不懂
Tasha: I can't understand.
Katrina:  老铁
Katrina: Buddy...
Katrina:  你自由我扯
Katrina: You're free, I'll pull.
Tasha: 三是a是吧
Tasha: Three is A, right?
Jake: 是谁的呀
Jake: Whose is this?
Jake: 真的是你的
Jake: Is it really yours?
Katrina:  是我的呀
Katrina: It's mine.
Tasha: 那他这个e写的是啥呀
Tasha: Then what is this "E" written as?
Lucia: 那是我的哦
Lucia: That's mine.
Tasha: 一是c好行
Tasha: One is C, okay fine.
Jake: 好好来
Jake: Alright, let's go.
Alice: 公布答案
Alice: Announce the answers.
Jake: 公布答案
Jake: Announce the answers.
Jake: 一第一个是
Jake: The first one is...
Katrina:  我倒是写了
Katrina: I did write it down.
Alice: 哎呀
Alice: Oh no.
Jake: 一个是啥呀
Jake: What is the first one?
Alice: 第一个是啥
Alice: What is the first one?
Jake: 第一个是a
Jake: The first one is A.
Jake: 哈哈哈啊
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake: 第一个是农夫山泉
Jake: The first one is Nongfu Spring.
Jake: 第二个是啥
Jake: What's the second one?
Jake: 第二个是苏打水d嗯
Jake: The second one is soda water, D, uh huh.
Shure:  这倒是能尝出来嗯
Shure: That one you can definitely taste, uh huh.
Jake: 第三个是百岁山
Jake: The third one is Baisui Mountain.
Katrina:  二是b第三是c
Katrina: Two is B, third is C.
Jake: c第四个是e
Jake: C, the fourth one is E.
Jake: 这个都这不能不对了
Jake: This one can't be wrong.
Jake: 第五个是娃哈哈
Jake: The fifth one is Wahaha.
Jake: 是b
Jake: It's B.
Shure:  你还给人家改
Shure: You even changed it for them.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Katrina:  不小心就是
Katrina: It was unintentional.
Lucia: 哎呀这手控制不住
Lucia: Oh no, my hand couldn't be controlled.
Katrina:  ABC
Katrina: ABC
Jake: 我是不是
Jake: Did I...
Jake: 我是不是写错了
Jake: Did I write it wrong?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Alice: 第六个是啥呀
Alice: What's the sixth one?
Katrina:  FS
Katrina: FS
Jake: 第六个是
Jake: The sixth one is...
Jake: 第六个是娃哈哈
Jake: The sixth one is Wahaha
Lucia: 第六个是娃
Lucia: The sixth one is Wah...
Jake: 没有第五个是怡宝
Jake: No, the fifth one is Yibao
Jake: 第五个是怡宝
Jake: The fifth one is Yibao
Jake: 给你们一些surprise
Jake: Surprise for you all
Shure:  第五是怡宝
Shure: Fifth is Yibao
Lucia: 所以第五个是F
Lucia: So the fifth one is F...
Jake: 第五是一对
Jake: The fifth one is a pair
Jake: 第五是f
Jake: The fifth one is F
Lucia: 第六个是b
Lucia: The sixth one is B
Jake: 对
Jake: Correct
Lucia: 好吧我给人家写标上答案写错了
Lucia: Alright, I wrote the answers wrong
Katrina:  哎随便批吧
Katrina: Oh, just grade it casually
Shure:  你就只错了两个
Shure: You only got two wrong
Katrina:  真的吗纯瞎写
Katrina: Really? I just wrote randomly
Katrina:  2分钟写完
Katrina: Finished in 2 minutes
Shure:  农夫山泉和娃哈哈
Shure: Nongfu Spring and Wahaha
Shure:  顺序反了
Shure: The order is reversed
Shure:  剩下都是对的
Shure: The rest are correct
Lucia: 这是
Lucia: That's...
Jake: 几分啊
Jake: How many points?
Jake: 大家都几分啊
Jake: How many points did everyone get?
Jake: 来
Jake: Come on
Tasha: 这是谁的
Tasha: Whose is this?
Shure:  这是我的
Shure: It's mine
Jake: 好这个是我们
Jake: Alright, this is ours
Jake: 从我们从宇轩的乌鸦的考卷开始是吧
Jake: Let's start from Yuxuan's crow's paper, right?
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Oh
Katrina:  3分
Katrina: 3 points
Lucia: 刚把这些都交回去了
Lucia: Just handed all these back
Shure:  哇哈乌鸦3分
Shure: Wow, the crow got 3 points
Katrina:  f b这是b是对的
Katrina: F B, this B is correct
Katrina:  对不起批卷老师有点那个哦
Katrina: Sorry, the grading teacher might be a bit...
Tasha: 4分天呐
Tasha: 4 points, oh my god.
Jake: 来大家看看有没有改错
Jake: Alright, everyone, see if there are any mistakes.
Jake: 呵呵呵太典了
Jake: Haha, this is classic.
Katrina:  批卷老师批错了
Katrina: The grading teacher made a mistake.
Katrina:  然后去办公室找批卷老师要
Katrina: Then go to the office and find the teacher.
Jake: 露西亚得了4分
Katrina:  天呐
Katrina: Oh my god.
Jake: 修硕几分啊
Jake: Shure, how many points did you get?
Jake: 你也是4分
Jake: You got 4 points too.
Shure:  但是我把怡宝选对了
Shure: But I got the Yibao question right.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 你选几分
Jake: How many points did you get?
Katrina:  我也是4分
Katrina: I got 4 points too.
Jake: 都是4分
Jake: Everyone got 4 points.
Shure:  呀
Shure: Yeah.
Alice: 3
Alice: 3.
Shure:  最后一个交卷
Shure: Last one to hand in.
Shure:  和第一个交卷的人答案是得分
Shure: And the first one's score is...
Shure:  这个得分一样
Shure: The same score.
Jake: 几分
Jake: How many points?
Katrina:  2分
Katrina: 2 points.
Jake: 2分
Jake: 2 points.
Jake: 你为什么得2分
Jake: Why did you get 2 points?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Jake: 好这是3分
Jake: Alright, this is 3 points.
Jake: 2分3分一排4分
Jake: 2 points, 3 points, and a row of 4 points.
Jake: 那决胜一下
Jake: Let's have a tiebreaker.
Katrina:  好石头剪刀布
Katrina: Alright, rock-paper-scissors.
Katrina:  石头剪刀
Katrina: Rock-paper...
Tasha: 他们仨
Tasha: The three of them.
Shure:  他仨
Shure: Those three.
Jake: 怎么决胜呢
Jake: How to tiebreak?
Katrina:  石头剪刀布
Katrina: Rock-paper-scissors.
Jake: 你们你们喝出吧
Jake: You guys, you guys drink and guess.
Jake: 你们喝出来这这这
Jake: You guys drink and guess these...
Jake: 3瓶矿泉4瓶矿泉水的味了吗
Jake: The taste of these 3 bottles of mineral water?
Lucia: 两瓶纯净水两个矿泉水
Lucia: Two bottles of purified water and two bottles of mineral water.
Lucia: 只能看别的
Lucia: Only look at others.
Lucia: 大概
Lucia: Maybe
Katrina:  这这位不是专业嘛
Katrina: Isn't this guy a professional?
Katrina:  他说他
Katrina: He said he...
Shure:  我怡宝是能喝
Shure: I can drink Yibao
Alice: 怡宝比较甜
Alice: Yibao is sweeter
Shure:  对怡宝真的是这里面最甜的
Shure: Yeah, Yibao is definitely the sweetest among these
Alice: 然后农夫山泉有一点辣嗓子
Alice: And Nongfu Spring is a bit harsh on the throat
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Ah
Alice: 有点涩然后他没有味
Alice: It's a bit astringent and it has no taste
Alice: 然后他有一点点那种
Alice: And it has a bit of that...
Shure:  好像
Shure: Seems like
Shure:  好像只有农夫山泉是偏碱性的
Shure: Seems like only Nongfu Spring is slightly alkaline
Alice: 就农夫山泉不太好喝
Alice: So Nongfu Spring isn't very good
Shure:  我也觉得
Shure: I think so too
Katrina:  哦我喝出来了
Katrina: Oh, I can taste it now
Alice: 怡宝比较甜
Alice: Yibao is sweeter
Jake: 好那这样吧我们
Jake: Alright, let's do it this way
Jake: 我来看一下
Jake: Let me take a look
Katrina:  哎不对不对不对
Katrina: No, no, no
Katrina:  嗯农夫山泉是几啊
Katrina: Hmm, what number is Nongfu Spring?
Shure:  农夫山泉
Shure: Nongfu Spring
Shure:  农夫山泉是一
Shure: Nongfu Spring is one
Jake: 好这样吧
Jake: Alright, let's do this
Jake: 我们来看一下各位手机的电量
Jake: Let's check everyone's phone battery levels
Jake: 然后决定这个
Jake: And then decide
Jake: 最后的赢家
Jake: The final winner
Tasha: 我已经失败了
Tasha: I've already lost
Shure:  我也是百分之18
Shure: I'm at 18%
Katrina:  50
Katrina: 50
Lucia: 96
Shure:  哇
Shure: Wow
Jake: 哇
Jake: Wow
Lucia: 昨天晚上刚充的电
Lucia: I charged it last night
Lucia: 早上就拔下来
Lucia: Unplugged it this morning
Jake: 恭喜96号玩家
Jake: Congrats to player 96
Katrina:  晚上也充了玩
Katrina: I charged it too and played
Katrina:  玩到了50
Katrina: Played to 50
Tasha: 没关系
Tasha: It's alright
Jake: 好的那我们就按照这样的顺序
Jake: Okay, then we'll follow this order
Jake: 96
Alice: 96
Jake: 呃 96
Jake: Uh, 96
Jake: 先选礼物对吧
Jake: First, choose gifts, right?
Jake: 一会我们会把每个人的礼物给拿上来
Jake: In a bit, we'll bring up everyone's gifts.
Jake: 介绍介绍
Jake: Introduce them.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure:  嗯我们要自己拿一下是吗
Shure: Hmm, do we need to bring them ourselves?
Jake: 对你们自己拿上来
Jake: Yes, you bring them up yourselves.
Jake: 然后我们把披萨也拿上来
Jake: And we'll bring up the pizza too.
Jake: 你们就边吃边聊吧好吧
Jake: You guys can eat and chat, okay?
Jake: 然后这个水就当边吃披萨边喝就好了
Jake: And you can drink the water while eating the pizza.
Katrina:  好这是我的
Katrina: Okay, this is mine.
Jake: 这是你们的饮品
Jake: These are your drinks.
Katrina:  一天8杯水
Katrina: Eight glasses of water a day.
Lucia: 哈哈哈一天8杯水
Lucia: Hahaha, eight glasses of water a day.
Lucia: 这才6杯
Lucia: This is only six glasses.
Lucia: 还差两杯
Lucia: Two more to go.
Jake: 大家把礼物拿上来吧
Jake: Everyone, bring up your gifts.
Jake: 好吧一天可是一杯也没喝呀
Jake: Alright, not even one glass today.
Katrina:  今天可是一杯也没喝呀
Katrina: Not even one glass today.
Lucia: 我看看我给里面装东西了吧
Lucia: Let me see if I put something inside.
Lucia: 别光带了个盒就搞笑了
Lucia: It'd be funny if it's just an empty box.
Shure:  没事客气了你
Shure: No worries, you're too polite.
Alice: 就出去倒点
Alice: Just go out and get some.
Shure:  我闻到有榴莲的披萨了
Shure: I smell durian pizza.
Jake: 我们把这个
Jake: We'll put this...
Tasha: 不是这个
Tasha: Not this one.
Jake: 啊
Jake: Oh.
Tasha: 没事不是
Tasha: It's okay, not this one.
Jake: 哪个
Jake: Which one?
Lucia: 这水把它掺一块
Lucia: Mix this water together.
Lucia: 然后
Lucia: And then...
Tasha: 卖苏打水和元气森林
Tasha: Selling soda water and Yuanqi Forest.
Lucia: 呃和元气森林已经喝完了
Lucia: Uh, we've already drunk the Yuanqi Forest.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Tasha: 啊
Tasha: Oh.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Lucia: 这样我能节约点空间
Lucia: This way I can save some space.
Lucia: 给他两杯合一杯
Lucia: Combine two glasses into one.
Katrina:  磕
Katrina: Haha.
Jake: 对都喝吧都
Jake: Yeah, everyone drink up.
Jake: 然后这个披萨大家一起摆一摆
Jake: And then let's arrange this pizza together.
Alice: 哎不得先交换吗
Alice: Hey, shouldn't we exchange first?
Alice: 先交换
Alice: Exchange first.
Jake: 边吃边
Jake: Eat while...
Jake: 边吃边聊
Jake: Eat while chatting.
Lucia: 本餐厅招募信息如下
Lucia: The recruitment information for this restaurant is as follows.
Jake: pizza Tuesday pizza first day
Tasha: 榴莲的在这个箱子里
Tasha: The durian one is in this box.
Tasha: 啊哎
Tasha: Ah hey
Lucia: 怎么这么多啊
Lucia: Why is there so much?
Lucia: 还有小食是吗
Lucia: Are there snacks too?
Katrina:  鸡哥
Katrina: Chicken bro
Lucia: 这是小龙虾味
Lucia: This one is crayfish flavor.
Katrina:  我好想吃小龙虾
Katrina: I really want to eat crayfish.
Lucia: 那可以把小龙虾摆的靠那边一点
Lucia: Then you can place the crayfish ones a little further over there.
Lucia: 我没看错吧
Lucia: Am I seeing this right?
Lucia: 上面写的好像是小龙虾
Lucia: It seems to say crayfish on it.
Tasha: 这个和这个一样
Tasha: This one is the same as this one.
Tasha: 放到这哎
Tasha: Put it here, hey.
Jake: 这个是一样的吗
Jake: Is this one the same?
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Lucia: 照烧牛肉
Lucia: Teriyaki beef.
Lucia: 哦我以前很喜欢吃这个味
Lucia: Oh, I used to love this flavor.